over 30 hours after the attempted
insurrection and three months after the
election
u.s president donald trump has now
acknowledged joe biden's win
he has also changed his tone from
previously telling the rioters he loved
them
to now calling the storming a heinous
attack a police officer has died of his
injuries following clashes with the
pro-trump mop
two days late fresh fortifications
around the u.s capitol building after an
angry mob
invaded the altar of american democracy
[Music]
those who attacked journalists
and police are now being attacked by
their leader
who himself is under intense fire the
demonstrators who infiltrated the
capital
have defiled the seat of american
democracy
to those who engage in the acts of
violence and destruction
you do not represent our country and to
those who broke the law
you will pay we have just been through
an intense election
and emotions are high but now tempers
must be cooled
and calm restored america's next
president
joe biden lays the ugly insurrection
squarely at trump's feet
he unleashed an all-out assault
on our institutions of our democracy
from the outset and yesterday was about
the culmination of that unrelenting
attack
amid the aftermath even former allies
have called for trump to be removed
immediately here's the truth the
president
caused this the president is unfit
and the president is unwell and the
president
must now relinquish control of the
executive branch voluntarily or
involuntary
mr vice president but vice president
mike pence who has the power to begin
that process
has said he will not do so
speaker of the house nancy pelosi is
threatening to impeach trump
for a second time by inciting
sedition as he did yesterday he must be
removed from office
while it's only 13 days left
every any day can be a horror show
for america members of trump's
administration have since resigned
including the transportation secretary
and most recently
education secretary betsy devos they
must
fully open and for more on this let's
bring in peter matthews he's a professor
of political science at cypress college
in california mr matthews
good to have you with us a clear change
of tone there from wednesday
when donald trump called those involved
in the storming of the capital very
special
and said he loved them to him now
speaking out against the violence and
saying they'll be an
orderly transition tell us how did this
u-turn come about
it's typical donald trump he's done it
so many times during the last four years
he'll say one thing he'll reverse
himself he'll reverse the tone
it's all about himself he wants to
protect himself he doesn't want to be
the first
president to be removed by the 25th or
25th amendment which was
bound to happen the way things are going
and he just wanted to cover himself and
decided to go ahead and be nice
i don't trust him one bit in terms of
his change of tone and i don't trust the
people that followed him
into the capital and he incited them to
go to the capitol at the noon
lunch that he had he had a speaking
engagement there in front of thousands
he told them to go in there go to the
capitol
and he said we've been cheated of the
election and he's incited the violence
and now he's trying to play nice
pressure is clearly
mounting on trump though there's talk on
capitol hill of impeachment
or invoking the 25th amendment what do
you believe will happen
we haven't predicted such a short time
we have less than two weeks left and
that time makes a difference
if out of the two i don't think the it's
tough the 25th amendment is going to
take
a majority of the cabinet to vote to go
ahead and change power from trump to
pence
and if he if trump objects and even
though the cabinet votes for it
then it goes to each house and each
house has to vote by two-thirds
majority to override trump's objection
and then the power shifts to
to uh to by defense so that's a bit of a
reach right now with just 10 days left
but the impeachment could occur
if enough people are riled up in the
senate the house will impeach him but
the senate has to convict him
and last time they failed to do that but
now things have changed a lot since his
insurrection
and let's call it what it was it wasn't
a riot it wasn't something random people
having fun drinking and getting drunk
and breaking windows
this was a planned insurrection against
a lawfully elected government
administration
and the processes of it so that's what
happened yesterday and i don't know
exactly what will happen with the two
would happen
but people are riled up and even
probably republicans and democrats
are calling for his resignation or
removal it seemed that this attempted
insurrection took police and security
around the capitol by surprise but many
reports suggest
far-right social media users had been
posting hints of their intentions
how could law enforcement ignore these
signs
that is a very puzzling question that
has to be answered it has to be
investigated very deeply and carefully
now
to find out where things went wrong
because how could
these thousands of people enter the
capital take over
the floor of the senate desecrate the
place and break the the windows and get
in and
and take pick up papers from the desks
of senators
and not anyone getting hardly anyone
getting arrested i mean in the end so
far they're saying that 60 people were
arrested or so
there were there were hundreds of people
in that in that building and yet why
were the police not able to stop them
why was the national guard standing much
earlier and finally
vice president pence is the one who
actually acted to activate
the national guard the dc national guard
president trump did not bring them in
and it was too long the senators and
congress people were lying on the floor
fearing for their lives they were locked
in they were hiding in place this is a
total disgrace to the world
and a very dangerous situation that has
happened and someone has to pay the
price for it someone has to
be held accountable for this absolutely
all right peter matthews professor of
political science at cypress college in
california thank you for your time
thank you so much take care i'm joined
now by alexander graf lamstov deputy
leader of the pre-democratic party in
germany's parliament the bundestag he
specializes in foreign policy mr lamstov
good to have you with us tell me what do
you make of the developments in
washington
of the past two days well there's bad
news and good news the bad news is of
course that we have
five people dead as a consequence of
these riots
the good news is that the mob
failed to overturn the constitutional
proceedings
trump failed in his butchered
pseudo-coup attempt and as a matter of
fact democracy won i mean
rule of law one decency won in the end
we now have a finalized american
election process
we have the prospect of joe biden being
inaugurated
um as is the due course of the american
constitution
on january the 20th on the steps of the
capital so
there's terrible news for the people who
have passed away
and their loved ones but there's good
news for american democracy
many people say they were shocked but
not surprised how about you
that's exactly the way i feel um having
listened
to donald trump over the years having
listened to him in the run-up to the
election on november 3rd
you could see that he was planning
things like this when he says emotions
are high after the election well he's
the one
who stoked the flames he's the one who
put in doubt the
very date of the election he's the one
who declared his democratic opponents
enemies of the people he is the one who
is responsible for all of this
and so i you know i have observed
elections in many countries across the
world
in africa in asia and whenever you see
authoritarian figures
trying to create a situation that is not
purely constitutional
that is not cleanly electoral they do
exactly what the american president has
done over the last couple of months
and then i watched his march his rally
earlier prior to the proceedings on
capitol hill
in the senate chamber and he clearly
incited his followers to walk over to
the capitol
and to start writing so there's
absolutely no doubt that
mr trump is responsible for what
happened there
yesterday how do you see these events
affecting
the u.s legitimacy in the promotion of
democracy and democratic values around
the world
well it's been a shock to the system
there's no doubt about that but on the
other hand as i just said
on the very same day that we saw the
riots taking place in dc on
on the steps and inside the capital in
the state of georgia
two opposition senators were elected
into office
and georgia is a state with a republican
administration the governor is
republican
the secretary of state is a republican
the man who leads the election process
is a republican
but they duly and correctly certified
the democratic
winners of their senatorial race which
means that joe biden now has a majority
both in the house
and in the senate to me that says that
mr trump
will be gone but american democracy will
remain strong
and with it also american credibility
when it comes to
talking about democracy yes it was a
shock yes it has done some damage
but by and large and looking at the
bigger picture i see
in my american democracy having come out
as the victor of this
of these these terrible images there
despite
it all could you uh see this incident
emboldening right-wing extremists in
other countries
yes indeed i mean we have seen similar
images in germany
if you recall in august we had a group
of people storming the german parliament
building
they did not make it inside but we had
very similar images
flags of the right-wing extremists of
nationalists
of populist racist types who were trying
to storm the capital to create
the sorry the reichstag building the the
german parliament uh
building um because they they feel that
parliamentary democracy is not
you know what they want they want an
authoritarian form of government
and yes of course democracies are
vulnerable around the world
every democrat whether you're left
center or right
needs to be very clear that the other
people whom you compete with
in democratic competition are not your
enemies they are your legitimate
competitors and if we can agree on that
if
and if we can convince more people in
our you know population including those
who have been seduced by radical
ringleaders then i think democracy
will come out strengthened but yes
democracy is under pressure and we have
to fight back
alexandercraft lamstoff deputy chair of
the fdp parliamentary group here in
germany many things
thank you